joined now by the sun's royal
photographer arthur edwards hello to you
arthur how you doing
how are you doing kate i'm fine thank
you and very well also arthur thanks for
joining us this morning how important
today
is this for the brothers well it's
important
hopefully that they can uh shake hands
and get over this rift that's come
between her because uh
one thing their mother uh would want is
that to happen
uh yeah i'm sure that's true how
difficult do you think it might be
though because it does look as though
it's been
pretty hostile over the last few weeks
and months
well i think um probably won't happen
but you know that's what we've got to
hope for i mean harry was a very
fightable member of the royal family
when he was
when he was lived here and i mean
william i remember their
the 10-year concert after dynavous dead
10 years at wembley
they organized this fantastic concert
for their mother they did that together
and now they're just doing everything
apart and it's um
i find it very sad has your relationship
changed with harry because you know
i've spoken to you many times about him
over the years and you used to get on
really well he would go down to the pub
with the journalists after a shoot or
whatever
uh what's it like now well of course he
never talks to us now he's uh he's gone
very hostile he won't let any of his um
his spokesman talk to us um he's just
cut us completely out and uh
yesterday he did an engagement with well
child now i've covered that
event many times with harry it's a
wonderful event he gets really
involved with the children but yesterday
no one we didn't know about it until
they issued the pictures
got someone to do it and not no no
member of the press was involved
that's how he wants to do it now he
wants to control everything and
it just um it just it's sad for me
because
he was one of the greatest people to
work with wherever you went with him in
the world
he would just give you fantastic
pictures and uh
and enjoy it and enjoy enjoy the job
join being prince harry enjoying sort of
making things great for people
especially kids
excuse me excuse me he does say that
he uh didn't enjoy being a royal do you
think that that's not always the case
i know i was there when when he was in
jamaica racing against usain bolt i was
there in new zealand
when he was playing football with the
kids on on the beaches of rio de janeiro
playing touch rugby with street kids oh
no he he
he gave so much he so much and i
you know he only changed not wanting to
be a royal
when he married megan after before that
i mean william
and catherine they were sort of a team
they
they achieved so much certainly with
their um with their their mental health
charity i mean they were sort of making
great progress with that
how do you think charles views what's
going on
well i think he's incredibly sad i mean
you know he doesn't see his
grandchildren he now has two
grandchildren in america doesn't see
them probably gets photographs but
that's not enough he uh there's no
prospect of
megan bringing the children here anyway
i mean she would she would have brought
them with harry on this trip
but so that's sad for him but also
losing daily contact with his son i mean
this this man harry
or in two campaigns in afghanistan
he did an awful lot for this country not
just as a member of the royal family
remember the
armed forces and we mustn't forget that
and you know he is a
a top man and i can't tell you the fun
i've had with him the the laughter i've
had with him the sort of
the way him and william just took the
mickey out of each other all the time
but
you know great love between them and
that's gone now and that's the saddest
part of all
what's the most we can expect from today
arthur do you think
oh i think they'll be polite to each
other for the sake of the cameras
there's going to be a no no it's not
going to be broadcast live they didn't
want that
they want any photographers there only
one from the press association
they i think they're they'll be they'll
be settled to each other after all
they've been brought up properly and how
do you think diana
would feel about the way they're
behaving to each other at the moment
i think she just bashed their heads
together i know she would she wouldn't
put up with this
i mean those boys were inseparable
everything they did together
everything they they had a magnificent
tree house at highgrove
they had the best toys you could get
they were always together
always together and and now they're just
thousands of miles apart and not only
the distance but
in their hearts as well arthur it's so
sad isn't it um thank you
for um sharing your experiences with us
as always it's great to see you